well this is a good opportunity to segue
over to the next intersectional you want
to rag on one of our birds of prey of
course I mean if it falls right in line
doesn't it sure yes it's like it's
glorifying what is that I don't yeah I
guess mediocrity glorifying mediocrity
well so the next segment we have is
birds of prey
Kathy Yin says undo expectations for
birds of prey were an extra burden on
her own oh is that why the movie did bad
do you want to look up that wouldn't do
the media force we can see what's box
office results
it did not do $0 I think it was a flat
though because the marketing budget was
really really high so here's what's
bounding into comics reports Kathy Yin
spoke on the performance of her big
studio debut birds of prey which
floundered in its opening weekend and
swiftly made it to digital VOD in the
wake of the ongoing pandemic that's not
fair though had nothing to do with the
pandemic it was going okay that's why
it's not fair I hope by now none of you
have normally would say like by now
you've probably seen this movie no most
of you probably haven't but you never
cared about spoilers anyway so this
movie was awful don't go see it it's not
worth it
you can't now anyway right no you can't
yeah we're all we're all well in well
now it's on video isn't it then they I'm
sure you can down no no I've seen it on
something you can download it it's like
don't waste your money
here we go you ready for this do it she
told The Hollywood Reporter everyone was
pretty quick to jump on a certain angle
after the film's lack of success and
edits she had an extra burden on her as
a woman of color oh okay she said quote
yeah I think that if you actually look
at the details of the budget breakdown I
know that the studio had really high
expectations for the movie as we all did
there were also undue expectations on a
female lead movie and what I was most
disappointed in was this idea that
perhaps it proved that we weren't ready
for this yet that was an extra burden
that as a woman of color director I
already had on me anyway so yes I think
there were certainly different ways you
could interpret the success or lack of
success of the movie and everyone has a
right to do that but I definitely do
feel that everyone was pretty quick to
jump on us
certain angle hmm hmm you know it's
funny she's covering her bases well this
is this is absolutely in line with the
previous something we just did on over
you know obese people and vet you know
body positivity stuff mm-hmm
a refusal refusal to accept
responsibility for your failure boom
yeah that's all it is absolutely you
know that she doesn't want to be sucked
right there you go he doesn't it thanks
for hanging out everybody it's been fun
we're good to go the movie sucked it did
it was a bad movie III and you know III
wanted it to be good I went into this
watching it thinking please be good
please I was like you know I I didn't
mind Suicide Squad it was entertaining
yeah you know I went in thinking this
might be entertaining and I was just
like I don't understand how and it just
got worse and worse and worse as the
movie went on well a really good a
really a really good example of one of
these weird things they did was the
women were kind of frumpy right so there
was one scene where Huntress is looking
in the mirror trying to like say her
name
and it's mary elizabeth winstead who is
very attractive but they dress her down
and they made her look bad it's like
look any person who wakes up and rolls
out of bed is not going to look good
right everyone you know will trim their
beer every man will well not every man
but whoa whoa whoa I don't trim my beard
you don't trim it just it comes and then
I get rid of it I would do it yeah well
the point is people groom themselves
sure yes whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold
on no I don't Oh everybody takes care of
themselves to some whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah but in this movie they have the
scene where Huntress is like rolled out
of bed mm-hmm and I thought it was
strange because yet there's actually a
photo set this this woman did and I
don't think is like a feminist thing but
she took pictures of people and then
took pictures of them with like pushing
out their guts and like mashing their
chins and making nasty faces yeah so
that people can see you like how you can
make someone look really good with
proper angles right you've done you've
done
I did one photo shoot for a magazine and
it was so incredibly painful have you
had experiences
with photo shoots where they're like
Archer back this way put your arm like
this now don't move for 20 minutes Adam
probably had I've been wearing a wolf
suit in 110 degree weather and I've also
been soaking wet on a glacier whoa
and I told not to be in a sled while
snow was being thrown at me yeah so I've
had both extremes yeah it exists it's it
sucks I - you know devote yourself for
the role that you're hired for you know
well so what what they did in this movie
was so they get I'm not trying to be
mean to these these women okay I'm just
trying to point out the reason why we we
choose escapism why we go into fictional
fantasy worlds is to live better to
experience things that we can't normally
experience so when we play video games
when we read comments we watch movies we
want to see the the the super-ripped
Captain America guy jumping off a
building falling 20 stories and then
rolling out of it and going like girl
and you know he's showing how strong he
is right there there's a thing they
describe in comics like Batman has no
superpowers but he has peak human
efficiency yeah exactly
like he's the best a human could
possibly be yep and we like we like that
you achieved some greatness mm-hmm you
know what I really like in comics as I
like characters who don't have powers
who have earned it who are extremely
skilled have technology I like Iron Man
I like Batman yeah and what I like about
the MCU is a lot of the characters just
have technology that's true yeah so
we're eating also yep yep Falcon Black
Widow Black Widow Hawkeye yeah they're
regular people yeah and their superhero
look it's flying I really like it I do I
do and some movie math powers
and like Watchmen was cool it was
basically about you know well not the
new one but the movie in the comic it's
about people who are superheroes and
they just wear masks and fight so that
that's cool that we're looking at the
best a human could possibly be birds of
prey was not that it was from be
overweight out-of-shape failures I was
watching this movie and I was like well
they're making me feel better about how
I look when I get up in the morning but
that's not what I'm here for
like you can just look in the mirror I
guess what I'm trying to say is you know
do
we have a superhero movie with a bunch
of fat dudes like out of shape men who
can't run very fast the blob was a bad
guy but an x-men universe yeah
but so that was a new year oh there's a
mutant power yeah that's a good point
like he was indestructible apparently
well nobody liked Thor when he was
overweight right why would they that's a
good point they tried to do that yeah
they did that and it's night or some
people said was actually cool and
there's a good point that I didn't mind
it well with the dreadlocks it actually
looked more like a real Viking Norse
Vikings actually look instead of like
this weird vendee muscle we do for
Hollywood well it really just looked
like he let himself go and that's what
was happening in the film because he
blamed himself so he let himself go Yeah
right it was like actually part of the
plot long curly haired dreads naturally
I have long curly hair and I've got
dreads in my hair sometimes that I need
to get rid of you know as I said I don't
really take care of my hair just kind of
shove it in this beanie and that's it
that's all I do yeah I don't I don't get
it it's almost like actually we've
talked about it before they tried to do
like a female Deadpool right you're
saying that they make these choices
where they feel morally justified in
making you entertaining and unappealing
content I wanted this I still want this
movie to be better than it was I because
I actually think of all the movie was
her name Margot Robbie yeah she's the
main character she she did great I
thought yeah she could be a female
Deadpool if they did it correctly but
they didn't do it correctly they made it
all like cheesy instead of like gritty
like I wanted it to be the gritty Gotham
this is it was Gotham I honestly just
realizing that that was Gotham what wait
a minute you know it's like daytime
Gotham's like oh that's why it doesn't
make sense the movie is just a bad like
I wanted grittiness well full-on
Huntress made no sense yeah the costumes
were like low-budget trash yeah they so
apparently the the short fat little
asian girl was Cassandra Cain who's
supposed to be bat woman and this
actually wait seriously
Batgirl or some like that yeah and it
offended a ton of like SJW type comic
fans okay because because
Sandra Kane is as I think bet woman has
a mental illness okay or as like neuro
atypical and so they basically removed
her and created this chubby little asian
girl who in no way is bet woman and
we're angry saying whether they just
ablest washed or whatever they call it
there's no way to look
they think they're morally justified to
making bad content with frumpy
characters that are unappealing because
it's morally right no dude I want to see
a dude who's like doing stupid things
like like Fast and the Furious I want to
see the rock hold a helicopter by a
chain and a car and go and pull the
helicopter off from a cliff so it like
you know say I'm talking about yeah and
really it's ridiculous or Captain
America hauling the helicopter in Winter
Soldier less silly it it's still silly
so silly
but it's supposed to be it's a movie we
don't we don't you don't need to make
them you know busty big tittied you know
women and skimpy clothes right but but
the way they did it was like it looked
like they rolled out of bed to like make
a point about beauty or something yeah I
actually really don't want people who
look just like me I don't want it to be
relatable I went for a story something
different and interesting in Deadpool
you had that dude who was friends with
him you know talking with TJ Miller I
think his name is yeah name and he was
he was like a crusty bartender right
it's fine if somebody is the character
is meant to be gross or whatever right
but that makes you kind of look down
upon them you you hold them in a certain
light right exactly like Deadpool is
gross and funny and he gets like bullet
holes through him and you don't actually
see him but he's in a costume
why would like the people were supposed
to be rooting for be degenerate filthy
mongrel types that's it just it doesn't
work yeah I don't get a kick you know it
can work but it's so thick what they've
done I was watching and I'm like I know
what they're doing mm-hmm I know what
they're doing and they even mentioned it
I feel like those at some point they
talked about how they didn't want to
make them attractive what did they have
a reason why because it's feminism
something about the male gaze I'm sure
well they it was rated R so that you
couldn't get young
girls even though I saw in all the malls
when I was like in like the young you
know clothing shops exact same outfits
that are skimpy and small and it's like
but you're it serrated our film who are
you who is your demographic who like if
you're frumpy feminists on Twitter well
no wonder it bombed that's a small
window I'm not saying right you know
anything about those people but it's
like that's if that's all you're
catering to and you're expecting the
comic-book Batman like the Joker fans
that's not what this movie was it was
not one of them have you ever seen
episode of South Park where the hippies
throw a festival in South Park I don't
think so you seen this I don't know so
hippies start showing up to South Park
and Cartman freaks out and he tries to
go and exterminate they bees are
something ridiculous oh he gets arrested
okay the people who are running the city
are permitting the hippie Jam Fest they
eventually realize the hippies are over
running everything and there's too many
of them and they go and talk to Cartman
about like why are you trying to get rid
of hippies and he was like don't you
understand they're gonna take over and
they're gonna have a hippie festival
it'll last forever and the mayor goes
that'll be great we could use the extra
money and he goes hippies don't have
money and so that's what I see here they
make a movie catering to a tiny fringe
sect of weirdos on the internet yeah
who don't care to actually see the movie
and then they wonder why no one sees it
yeah they think Twitter is real life
right yeah yeah real people are like
what did I just watch like we walked out
confused like do I ask for my money back
can we can we make the box office
numbers go down after the fact no I've
actually tried getting my money back
after seeing a movie and that way they
told me to F off and I was like but the
movie was bad they were like yup lots of
movies are bad got me there yep but this
was definitely I mean the scene where
she she like squats on the roller skates
and then Banshee screams at her butt and
projects her forward what were they
thinking with this man it was really
silly it was awful but not silly in the
good
good way you know I know you're right
you know like there was one scene where
Harley dropkicks a dude okay as badass
there there is fighting there is a slim
a couple times where it's cool fight
scene yep like the evidence lockup
exactly that's actually does that she
drop kicks the guy and I'm like that's
cool
oh man that might be the only good fight
scene right yeah so they they definitely
tried doing like the Harley's gymnastic
you know acrobatic ability and fights
and stuff and he just didn't work out
like when she raids the police
department yeah nothing she's shooting
everyone with glitter bombs
why were they - nobody it for little
kids but right at our and nobody shot
back at her they were like hmm who's
this person in the police station
Oh glitter bomb it was rated R she
should have just just used regular
bullets I agree instead it was like oh
people glitter bombs it's like what III
understand they're trying to go for the
Harley you know aesthetic laughing gasps
glitter bombs and bean bags and all that
silliness that just just doesn't work
just kind of makes me feel like they're
infantilizing women yeah I like it I
thought it was terrible
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you